[Musique]
benjamin morel bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
plusieurs choses à retenir de ces
municipales tout d'abord la victoire
historique des écologistes notamment à
lyon bordeaux ou encore strasbourg
comment vous interpréter cette montée
des verts alors c'est une vraie victoire
c'est à dire que c'est la portée mais
très clairement ça montre qu'aujourd'hui
au sein des centres urbains
il vient l'espace de la gauche
sociale-démocrate et qualité et capté
solidement d'élection en élection depuis
les européennes par europe ecologie les
verts
après ce n'est pas non plus une victoire
qu'il faut je dirais surévaluée
c'est à dire que on a quand même un
focus avec les élections municipales sur
quelques grandes villes qui sociologique
nombre ne représente pas l'ensemble du
pays et quand on regarde l'ensemble de
la carte de france
on voit que beaucoup de maires ont été
la très grande majorité des maires ont
été nos premiers tours et sont plutôt
issus des vieilles formations classiques
socialiste et des républicains et que
quand on s'intéresse au but de moyenne
hier c'est plutôt la droite qui a
conforté ses positions à droite les
républicains
donc on a très clairement des prises
dans ces grandes villes dans ces grands
centres urbains
on a une sociologie de ses grands
centres urbains qui a évolué ces
dernières années l'a choisi younes
libournaise n'est plus la même que celle
qui existait il ya vingt ans donc pour
toutes ces raisons là c'est très
clairement une victoire mais ça ne
préfigure pas forcément une hégémonie
d'europe écologie les verts au sein de
la gauche en vue des présidentielles
alors on l'a dit un 2e tour marqué par
un taux d'abstention historique 1 soit
la cinquième république presque 60% des
électeurs inscrits ne se sont pas rendus
aux urnes
comment expliquer ce fort taux c'est on
va dire très attendu est sans doute est
ce assez naturel vous avez d'abord une
baisse de la participation aux élections
locales d'élection en élection depuis
des années est attendu ensuite vous avez
évidemment une abstention subi
notamment de la part une partie de
l'électorat g qui ne s'est pas déplacé
par thomas coville
vous avez ensuite une élection
extrêmement particulière en réalité avec
ce décalage entre les deux tours avec
probablement beaucoup d'électeurs qui ne
savaient même pas une élection avait
lieu dans leur commune
ça ne concernait qu'un nombre restreint
de communes ce second tour avec qui
fusent et des dynamiques de campagne qui
ont été rompues avec des projets
proposés au premier tour qui n'allait
pour certains plus réellement de sens au
second on regarde les crise des finances
locales qu'on va connaître avec la crise
économique
pour toutes ces raisons brrr on peut
difficilement s'étonner de ce taux
d'abstention
anne hidalgo à elle a été réelle à
parier devant rachida dati et agnès
buzyn déconvenue de plus pour la
république en marche
est-ce que la gestion de la crise
sanitaire a joué en défaveur du parti
probablement pas le mal vient de plus
loin
quand vous regardez les résultats du
premier tour la république en marche a
perdu ses élections dès le premier tour
la réalité c'est que ces candidats
étaient déjà souvent très loin derrière
voir déjà éliminés et gars partir de là
les espoirs de l'emporter est délimitée
à un certain nombre de villes dans très
restreint je pense à strasbourg accepté
à puisqu'ils ne se sont pas concrétisées
la réalité c'est que les tickets de la
république en marche lors de ces
élections a plutôt desservi ceux qui
s'en sont emparés et donc ça prouve que
au sein du pays très clairement aux
andelys et bien cette étiquette la
république en marche peu paradoxalement
par rapport à ces basses en 2017 faire
peur aux électeurs est plutôt détourner
leur vote
pour ce qui est du seul du vote
social-démocrate plutôt vers un vote
europe écologie les verts pour le vote
de droite plutôt vers des listes et la
loire vers l'abstention ce que les
candidats aient l'air qui se sont
rapprochés de la ruelle entre les deux
tours et bien non pas vraiment profité
merci beaucoup
benjamin morel d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que les acteurs en
sciences politiques à maître de
conférences à lui
merci tu es paris 2 et au lendemain